コミュニケーションが成り立つためのアドバイス
はい これからもう本当本番です
どうしよう で 仏教からのアドバイス
仏教が見るコミュニケーション
何をするか 自分が言いたいことを強調しても
他人が聞きたいことを強調しても
理性に基づいてコミュニケーション
コミュニケーションになりません
自分が言いたいことを言ったとしてもね
他人が聞きたいことを言ったっても
コミュニケーションではないんです
結局は他人が要求するものを与える場合も
自分の尊属を考えているわけです
例えば 私が人を何を聞きたいかとチェックして
それペラペラ喋る 人に何か開けていないんです
私も身の安全を考えているんです
タレントさんたちと同じです
初めからのコミュニケーションが不全っぽいです
ですから 私が喋ったならば
それ私の都合のために喋っているのです
私の自我のために 私の尊属のために
私の不幸のために喋っている
だからあまりにもコミュニケーションには余計ています
不全行為 そういうことで
仏教から見れば悪意ですよ
1自分のために語っているならば
それは正直に相手に言えばいいでしょうか？とアドバイスですよ
だから 詐欺師にならないでください
偽善者にならないでください
子供に君も勉強しなさいよ
君のためだと嘘を言わないでください
君が勉強してね 合格してお父さん楽しいやんと
お父さんに自慢できるんだよと
友達の前でうちの子はね
なかなかやってますよと
だから俺が自慢したいんだから
なんか頑張ってくれと言ったら
じゃあよし 頑張ってやると
どうせだらしないお父さんだから
なんとか助けてあげないと
子供は子供でそう思うんですよ
やっぱりお父さん助けてあげないと
それでうまくいきますよ
コミュニケーション お母さんも助けてあげる
お父さんも助けてあげるという気持ちにさせれば
子供に言うことを聞いてくれますよ
これ 全く偽善で詐欺ですからね
言っていることは だから聞かないんです
相手が自分のことを心配して聞いてくれる
理解する可能性が大いにあります
2理解することで互いに利点があることを確認すれば
両方が努力  2番目 これが理解すれば私も得して
あなたも得しますよという場合は
お互い頑張ります 例えば
学校の先生が君たちがみんな勉強して合格したら
私の立場 株が上がりますよ
これで君たちにも決して悪くないんだよ
東大合格とかしたらね
何かまずいことでもあるのか
だからお互い頑張ろうと言えば
子供たち話を聞く 正直だから
先生はね 私はなんで無期限で教えようかというと
本当は私の株も上がりたい
上がってほしいの だからお互い利益があるんだから
それ確認するんですよ
詐欺はダメなんです それからプレゼンテーションという
どのように語るのかということ
一輪の花は横に置くより花瓶に挿した方が 100 万倍も美しくなるんです
見る気になるんです 覚えておいてください
花市場のポッと置いた花
誰も見ようともしないです
ゴミのと勘違いする それをちょこっと挿しておくと
どれほど変わるのか だから
言う言葉に噂を入れないと言っただけでダメです
言葉とは自分の意見を相手に伝える道具です
常に相手の心は楽しい
明るい気分になるように
愛を語る習慣を身につけます
だから 一輪の花の例えで
我々は如何に愛を語るべきか
語るときは美しく 作品のごとく喋らなくてはいけないのです
そうすると聞いてくれます
言語で語っただけでは理解しがたいのです
言語は皿のように道具です
湯呑みの液体は湯呑みの液体は必ずしも茶である
ということはなりませんね
湯飲みの中の液体は必ずお茶
そんなことはあり得ないでしょう
言語が運ぶ意義は常に流動的であること
ですから そのつもりではなかったと言えないように気をつけましょう
あの言葉の意味は固定してないんです
じゃあこんちくしょうと言ったら怒ってる意味？なんにも持ってないんですよ
流動的なんです バカとおかしいと言ったらどんな意味？おかしいってことは笑えるって意味
全く違うでしょ 流動的なんです
言語で伝えなくちゃあかんだけど
言語からなんか あの なんかカエルを皿で集めるような感じですよ
集めたっても逃げちゃうんですよ
カエルちゃんを何匹ぐらい
普通のお盆でね お盆に置いていて運んであげたって
もうもう三分もう一匹もないんです
言語ってのはそんなもんで
意味が飛んでいくんですよ
これに気をつけないとです
もう一度頭の中身のパート通る入ります
人の頭の中はブクブクと煮立っているスープのようなものです
何を入れても一緒に煮てしまうんです
むちゃくちゃですよ 我々頭の中でブクブクと釜茹でてます
だからソフトクリームあげても釜にボーッと入れちゃいますから
言いたいことをうかつに言うと
相手の頭の中の何をとまず何と化するのかわかりません
時々あるでしょ？なんかおかしい
言ったことですっごい誤解してしまって
大喧嘩になって離婚するまでになったりして
あるいは会社は大損害受けたりとかね
あるいは仕事を辞める羽目になったりとか
例えばね 株関係の金融関係の人でも酒飲みながらね
もうじゃあ友達同士でね
あの昨日ね あれであれで
あのなんか言ったところで
これはなんて言いますか
インターとインサイダー取引情報をもらったと
もらってないんですよ
そういうことよくありますよ
それから この我々が人に言ったことで間違って理解してとんでもないことになるの
この頭の中のこの似ているスープは何なのかわからないんだからね
いつでもこれもう似ていますから
何喋ってもボーンと放り込むんです
相手の頭という箱の中を少々整理して
その隙間に自分の意見を入れるように入れるとよく入ります
だから本当はもう何も入る余地がない
もう何の整理整頓してない
すごい箱やと思ってください
人の頭 そこでなんとかなんとかなんとかちょこっと整理整頓して
ちょっと隙間があったらサッと自分が言いたいことを入れないと
ちょっと待ったらもう別のものが入ります
だからそういうものすごいこの何技という神技です
何が理解してもらうということ
神業なんです 私は結構経験があります
もう何年ももう何か言いたくて言っているんですけど
時々まあもうある子供が小さい時からあまりも乱暴で
もう必死で起こしたりして
もうハイパーテンションでみんな困っていて
で 子供さえも困っていて
もうなんとかならないのかと
で だから親も私に子供を仲良くしてくれと
子供も自分のあの自分の気持ちですごく泣いているんですけど
私は仲良くしてこないで
ちょっと下手でも何やるかわからない
でも私の気持ちではなんとか言いたいんですよ
子供にしっかりしなさい
でも入らないとこを知っているので行っている
かえって発作を起こしたらどうします？そこでじっと待っていると
待っていると 待っていると
毎日毎日毎日毎日 ある瞬間
二 三秒が空いたんです
ちょっと二 三秒 これ二
三秒で一言言ったんです
それ終わり もう人生カラッと変わった
あの子は それからもう信じられないいい子になって
もう信じられない もうびっくり
なんで人格そこまで変わったのだと
だからこれできればね
神技もの神技なんです
だから頭の中でちょっとでも隙間があった途端
もう情報を入れたら入ります
まあ無理でしょう ですからね
何を言う 自分が言いたいことをも
他人が聞きたいことを提供するのもコミュニケーションではないし
不戦行為なのです だから言うもの
これから全部アドバイスですよ
私が言いたいことを言っちゃうと
これ不戦行為です 人が聞いたいことを言うと
それも不戦行為です コミュニケーションではないです
事実は何か 互いに役に立つ情報は何かということという発見するために語るんです
これ仏教のアドバイスです
事実は何なのか 一方的に子供に怒鳴り叱るんじゃなくて
事実は何なのか どうなっているのかと
で 役に立つことは何なのか
そのために喋る 私の意見でも相手の意見でもなく
知るべきものを知るためなんです
喋るの 知るべきことを知るために喋るんです
自分の意見を通してもらうためじゃないのです
随分違いますね 仏教の見方は
恐ろしく違います ちなみに無駄話
噂 嘘 悪語は罪です 仏教の悪語っていうのは粗悪語ですけど
漢字は出てこなかったんです
人を怒鳴ったりすること
叱ったりすること そんなのは仏教では罪です
その次 語るときの気持ち
都合で語り 語ると利害関係が割り込みます
語りではない 自分の都合で語ると
利害関係 聞いてみると
これ損するかも 損するかもと警戒するし
あるいは得する話やと言って受け取ったりする
で 自分もこんなこと言っちゃうと私が損するかも
こんなこと言っちゃうと得するかもと利害関係で喋ってますよ
だからコミュニケーションじゃないです
それでコミュニケーションは中断します
相手を慈しんで語る場合は理解しようとするものです
できれば人を慈しんで語るのです
幸福であってほしい 誰であって
慈しんで語ると聞きます
また間違いがあります
できない場合はでない場合ではなくて
慈しみができない場合は両方の利益を考えるべきなのです
普通 我々は慈しみで喋ることできない場合は
お互い様の利益のために喋りましょう
話すよりは聞く技を身につけることが大事です
みんな喋りたがってますけどね
一番立派なのは聞くことです
聞く技がある人は語る技を学ぶんです
人はいかに下手くそとわかるでしょ
そうすると自分が自動的に喋るようになっているのです
人は話したくうっすら溜まっているので
聞く人は大人気者です
みんな喋りたいんで 聞く人はいないでしょ
だから聞くこと能力がある人っていつでも人気なんです
無口な 無口なのに 知らないものを正直に伺う
もう一つ 自分が知らないことがあったら
正直にこれは何？どうなってる？教えてちょうだいと
よく聞いてください 人を
それがコミュニケーションです
そうすると相手が語る
自分が聞く 極めて悪人でない限り
人は他人にものを教えたいという気持ちでいるんです
人っていうのは人に教えたくて教えたくて
もうたまらんんですよ
時々私はこの三歳 四歳の子供たちにこれ教えてくれる？と言ったら
もう調子に乗って教えろ教えろ
言葉喋れない子はむちゃくちゃですけど
興奮しちゃって もうこっちだ知ってるんですけど
本当は くだらないゲームとかね
やり方を教えてくれるというと
えーとですね これはとかね
時々見事に教えてくれる場合があります
ということは 人間というのは人に教えたいんですよ
問題は生徒がいないんですね
だからお釈迦様 仏教会のみんな生徒になってあげたらどうですか？と問いますよ
知りたいことはどうと聞く
これってどういうこと？これどうなってる？よく教えちゃいますよ
忙しい時でも聞く 教えてくれる
人に聞くことでもコミュニケーションが成り立る
それでコミュニケーションです
なぜ自分が聞きたい 相手を教えたい
それでピッタリです